this has been a pretty long process for
you you know from obviously the events
and the book and the filming of it now
the film is coming out are you feeling
are you are you feeling good you're
satisfied I know you're exhausted I'm
exhausted physically a little bit
because of all the traveling but
otherwise no I think it's good because
it's part of the same process that is
started with writing the Newsweek
article and then the book and then doing
interviews when I came out and now the
film takes the message to another level
and provides a new platform to talk
about human rights issues in Iran and
the situation of journalists not only in
Iran but also around the world
your wife will never see you again two
things are happening at the moment one
is that information is being
democratized and at the same time we are
witnessing this knee-jerk reaction by
authoritarian regimes or authoritarian
institutions to this democratization
they try to combat the new flow of
information the new methods of gathering
information sharing information
disseminating information through the
old means of you know repressing and
suppressing the press you see the
criticism of the United States and the
way that journalists are being treated
by the administration here as kind of a
tool against press freedoms in places
like Egypt or what have you I think the
situation of many journalists in the
United States is not good but you really
cannot compare the situation in the u.s.
with many other countries I don't think
that it has to do anything with Obama
administration I think it has to do with
this explosion of digital media
explosion of information and any
government whether it was a Republican
government
kradic government whatever would have
the similar reaction to WikiLeaks to
Snowden to what happened in Ferguson if
these are the knee-jerk reactions to new
wave of information and social media
with anton chekhov anton chekhov the
blatant hey you told me it is you as
less than an interest of him on facebook
you spoken numerous times about the idea
that Iran is on a slow moving progress
towards reform towards democracy that
it's happening it's going slowly do you
see the election of rouhani as an
indication of that what happens during
the green movement was that people were
giving a chance to I told a hominid
primarily and to the regime as a whole
to reform itself and the demonstrations
on the street was an indication of this
widening gap between the people and the
leadership and some people some wise
people within the Islamic Republic
establishment understood that yeah and
they have told hominid through a variety
of ways and they persuaded him not to
rake this election anymore I am one of
those people who do not support regime
change in Iran because I think that
imagining this regime goes tomorrow who
is going to replace it whoever is going
to replace this regime has to come to
power has to use the same methods yeah
governance as this regime I think we
have to have changed within the Iranian
culture and that is happening what would
you like people to think when this movie
is done when they walk out of the
theater I think what really sustain me
during this 118 days of imprisonment
especially those 107 days of solitary
confinement was my experience of culture
music film poetry literature and also
the love of my family
the memory of my family in their hearts
they know they cannot win and although
the film is about imprisonment and about
suppression of protest it has a very
hopeful message that I think at the end
something good happens we're not going
to give out this we're giving that by me
you're here the film is called rosewater
thank you